we're both from Cleveland yeah awesome
tu-16 is the area code so you know that
easy right there if I'm ever homesick I
could just take a 71 north
ham steak 82 71 this one are you excited
about the Cavs winning oh yeah between
me you and the Brawn that's like three
kings please
got it there's a couple like three the
morning tattoos like the [ __ ] off right
there's yes was it was clearly like a
3:30 in the what's that about
it's just like when I've learned to sit
right here it's just like one of the
like the grimy displays ever got a
tattoo was in Reading Pennsylvania cuz
when I was working in my back I have a
Salvador Dali piece on my back it was
this really gross hotel we like get in
the room we set all the tattoos [ __ ] up
and we're like tattooing and I'm like
okay I'm gonna take a break to go to the
bathroom real quick you know I like the
corner miles and all the bathtubs like
still full or whatever that's weird okay
whatever but it was pee there's pee that
filled the whole entire bathtub we
wrapped the tattoo and you got the [ __ ]
out
gifts cars yeah yeah those are from
broken Jameson bubbles you want to touch
that I do not know this is one of my
favorites right here I got hit by a
double-decker bus in Manchester and four
double-decker bus crashes into us it's
miss i lo I like there's the little gate
stick there's me yeah at least 7:00 in
the morning
we were looking for we so I saw some
guys I was like that guy looks like you
would have it for sure I took one step
in in the street the bus is going full
speed the whole front of the windshield
is cracked like spider webs I woke up on
the ground
my clothes were ripped I tried to like
run away I was like so messed up that I
thought I did like a crime or something
did you get the weed though no what's
this one this is a like a black heart
stone-cold heart what's happening when
you spend so many years in this industry
like you really learn to harden yourself
and not let people in you're like me and
I feel like we're cool right yeah what
cool all right that's all I care about
Eastside yeah you know it's not right
that's a three she's so we have to
retouch my men three means